ترغب في تجنب الجلوس بجانب طفل يبكي
في رحلتك القادمة ، فإن الخطوط الجوية اليابانية
لديها خطة لك ، قدمت شركة النقل
ميزة جديدة على نظام الحجز على مواقعها على الويب
والتي تُظهر لك مكان
جلوس الأطفال الصغار ، تظهر أيقونة طفل
حيث يسافر الراكب
مع  طفل حتى سن عامين ، لكن
شركة الطيران تحذر من أن الأداة ليست
مضمونة ، فقد لا تظهر الأيقونة إذا
تم حجز التذكرة من خلال طرف ثالث
أو إذا كان هناك تغيير في اللحظة الأخيرة في
الطائرة بصفتك مسافرًا متكررًا للعمل
وطفلًا باكيًا.  لا يهم مكان
جلوسك على متن طائرة ، يمكنك سماع طفل يبكي
فقط ارتدي سماعات العلبة الكبيرة ،
نعم ، لكن لا توجد ستة صفوف تسمح
بمزيد من الهدوء والهدوء لمجموع الأعمال
من الأطفال حتى عندما يبكون